yes you can be smart and successful
and still struggle with add just like i
do
my favorite rule is never worry alone
with the hyperactive component of adhd
you can focus on things for i can out
focus any mother
any person in the room wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how to make adhd
your superpower enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get professional help with mel
robbins
yes you can be smart and successful and
still struggle with add just like i do
for a very long time the american
psychiatric association defined the
standards for add based on how it
manifested in little boys
and when girls have add in adhd it looks
really different they're not bouncing
around in their chair
they're daydreaming they're having a
hard time following instructions
and they're really disorganized and what
happens is a lot of girls
go undiagnosed and then that spirals
into
anxiety and depression why well because
if you have add
and you're not successful with treating
it or you don't have strategies to cope
with it
you tend to start to beat yourself up
you stand to start to make yourself
wrong for being so disorganized you tend
to start to feel
a little hopeless over your ability to
get things done
and that spirals and that's exactly what
happened for me you see i was diagnosed
with anxiety
when i was 21 years old boom
right there in that lost generation of
women we missed the diagnosis of add
in me instead it turned into anxiety and
depression and that became the primary
thing that i struggled with
now meanwhile the add was underneath
there untreated the entire
time when i got diagnosed at the age of
47 with add
it was so surprising and so empowering
because
i finally had a way to explain
something about the way that my mind
works that made a hell of a lot of sense
i also found the compassion that i
needed for myself
so that i could stop beating myself up
and actually just accept the fact that i
have a neurological
condition that makes me disorganized
forgetful
easily distracted and sometimes
scattered now what are the positive
effects well
i have a lot more humanity for myself
and i laugh at myself when i walk in the
kitchen and see that the faucet is still
running because i forgot to turn it off
instead of making myself wrong what ways
has it held me back
i think it's the source of my anxiety
that i suffered with for a very long
time there are plenty of projects that i
was
never able to finish in college or
law school or in jobs what are the
strategies that i use to cope with it
well number one
you gotta go see a professional so
having a doctor to talk
to about add has been extraordinarily
helpful
in understanding the way that my mind
works
and the strategies that i should be
using in order to set myself up for
success
get yourself educated after you talk to
a professional
so i love ned hollowell's book driven to
distraction i love john ratey's book
about spark and the connection between
exercise and add and depression and
anxiety
so get yourself educated i take adderall
not every day
not all the time i will for example take
it if i'm
on an airplane and i'm going to fly
across country and i have four hours in
a seat and i want to focus and get a lot
of work done i'll take it in that
instance
if i have a deadline and i'm finding
that it's hard for me to
focus i might take it then but that has
worked
really well for me i know a lot of
people abuse it i don't happen to be one
of those people that abuse it but
it has been a real life saver the other
thing that has
helped me a lot with add is exercise so
i noticed that right after i exercise
i typically have a two to three hour
window where i'm much more focused than
i normally
am and finally i notice a big connection
between my gut
and my add so i am a extremely healthy
eater because when i tend
to carbo-load or eat and mainline ice
cream or drink a ton of booze
what ends up happening is i get more
distracted
less focused and it has a negative
impact
on the add condition that i struggle
with
rule number two don't be hard on
yourself with brendan burchard
so when you see a sea of people from 40
countries raise their hand and go
oh i too have focus and discipline it's
hard for me
i want you to feel good about that i
want you to go oh man i'm
really hard on myself no breakthrough is
going to come from more judgment
no breakthrough more judgment
what the breakthrough is going to come
from is another level
of self-love and demand
now many of us in our lives who's ever
had
a sudden demand placed on you and you
kicked for like weeks
now keep your hand high if you are also
one prone to
lack of discipline and focus but you
still kick
that was necessity that's demand
we need something bigger than our
impulses
to keep us focused we need something
bigger than how we
to keep us disciplined when we talk
about service
we talk about dreams we talk about
mission the truth of that really is
we need that north star to get us out of
our funks
we need that north star to get us out of
bed
we need that north star and a connection
to it
to organize ourselves i don't think we
have to solve
i have a focus problem because you know
what i bet your focus problem is one
reason your clients think this guy's
pretty creative
i bet you come up with a lot of
different solutions and tools and
frameworks that help people
oh yeah oh yeah like you're good at some
weird
that's a wonderful thing
now what we just have to do is have that
why that that thing that's going to
organize you
all right my friend evan carmichael's
book listen humans are built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
rule number three believe in yourself
with michael phelps
what's up guys i'm michael phelps uh i'm
an olympic champion
and i have adhd
growing up i i was somebody who was
always constantly bouncing off the wall
i could never sit still
if i could go back in time and tell my
younger self something i would tell him
to
to believe what's in his heart and
never ever give up you know that's
something that that i've lived with my
whole entire life
and will continue to live with it's been
something that's changed my life
since the beginning you know i think you
know i think the biggest thing for me
once i
found that it was okay to talk to
somebody and and and
seek help um i think that's something
that that has changed my life forever
and and now i'm able to live
life to its fullest um we had kids
who you know we were all in the same
class and teachers would treat them
differently than they would treat me
um i had a teacher tell me that i would
never amount to anything and i would
never be successful
so it was a challenge and it was a
struggle but for me it was something i'm
thankful happened
and and i'm thankful that i am how i am
uh
i look at myself every day and i'm so so
proud and so happy of of
who i am and who i've been able to
become rule number four
never worry alone with dr ned hallowell
there is a lot of self-esteem and doubt
issues that seem to come with adhd and
even once you do start becoming
successful there's the imposter syndrome
that goes along with it how do you deal
with that
well my my favorite rule is never worry
alone
you know so my wife can tell you you
know i i wrestle with self-esteem issues
all the time
my wife knows all of she could
practically alphabetize them you know
and i think it's just part of adhd for
whatever reason and we can speculate as
to why
and so i i make light of it and that's
another way of dealing with it i also
look at reality you know i've done good
things and
and most people with adhd have done good
things so you you want to always appeal
to reality because we do have a terrible
tendency to dwell on
the negative and and overlook the
positive the book i wrote about worry i
began with the
opening scene where i was giving a
lecture grand rounds at harvard medical
school
and at the end of the presentation i got
a standing ovation
but there was one woman in the back of
the room who was scowling
and when i got home my wife said how did
it go and i said well there was this
woman at the back of the room who was
scowling
well she was wise enough to know to ask
them well how about the rest of the room
and i said oh they gave me a standing
ovation but what i dwelled on was that
one woman scowling at me so
we 80 years we lose perspective and we
often dwell on the negatives and that's
why i always say never worry alone you
know do some reality testing you want to
worry with the right people of course
but
you want to have the supports around you
where you can be real and be honest and
and get the kind of reassurances that we
really do need
rule number five focus on your passion
with kerwin
ray obviously super intelligent but then
school take it
but yeah i found it that's interesting
because i failed every subject
that's what i was getting every subject
from year 1 to year 12 i failed
what what that was you were diagnosed
with animals
at the age of seven and what when you
were diagnosed you were labeled as well
weren't you i was
labeled learning disabled i was always
told that i didn't learn like everyone
else and
i was a problem child in the classroom
and as a result
you know that affected every other
aspect and area of my life but very
unconsciously until my mid-20s
and as i said i started i read my first
book at age 23
and i'd never be able to read more than
a page or two because i didn't forget
what was on a page and
then the first time i actually read a
book that i was actually interested in i
remembered it
and that's what i've learnt with adhd
you know adhd to me gives me an untapped
amount of energy you've got to focus on
multiple projects at one time
but it also brings with an understanding
i've got a hyper sensitivity to boredom
yes and so for me you know someone with
adhd they're very sensitive to things
that they're not interested and they
will check out very quickly and they'll
become disruptive
whereas for me the key was actually
focusing on the things that i'm most
passionate about
and then with the hyperactive component
of adhd
you can focus on things for i can out
focus any mother
any person in the room so you really
have harnessed it as a superpower what
has been your way to
control those focus elements the biggest
the biggest thing i've used to control
when it comes to focus is meditation you
know
meditation is about essentially like
focusing the mind whether it be on a
mantra
or sensation or or breath to a point
where you
ultimately build an attention span rule
number six
turn it into a superpower with dan
martel some of the benefits
uh that i believe i've had is you know i
have the power to hyper focus
you know some people find it weird but i
do my best work in
airports coffee shops where there's a
lot of noise and distraction i don't
know if you do this but
i can't even work without having
background music on and sometimes that's
tv
you know for a long time when we had
this thing in canada called much music
i used to play music videos all the time
and not that i was listening to the
songs
i was just doing it as a as as kind of
like
this background white noise anyways
hyper focus when i when i bite into
something when i
decide to do something i go super deep
super aggressive
uh it's amazing the other benefit is
creativity i feel that
you know when i'm i'm with the team and
we're brainstorming different product
ideas
i just feel like my brain's able to kind
of look at different patterns and
connect things that
other people don't always see and i
always just thought it was maybe just
who i was but
i felt like as i met more creative
people more people that
on the surface you think that have add
they have this same
ability this this belief that you know
that whatever the problem or the
challenge is they're going gonna find a
solution and
that's why i believe that it is my
superpower and that a lot of people
might be on medication i believe you
need treatment you know
but i think there's a huge disconnect
between
medication and treatment i'm not an
expert i'm not a doctor but
read the books educate yourself you know
i do really simple things like
meditate in the morning to reset my mind
work out in the morning to kind of reset
my body and my energy levels
and i also do a thing called energy
management which i did a video on
recently
which talks about how i structure the
tasks and activities i do in my day
to really get the most out of it knowing
that this is the way my brain's wired
i've never looked at it as a disability
if anything i've
as i mentioned i think it's a it's a
super power it's an enhancement it's
it's who i am and i want everybody to
live who they are
rule number seven find the right
conditions with rick green
when did you know you had adhd um
i got the diagnosis around the year 2000
that was my y2k disaster but it was also
it was a relief it was like
this everything makes sense and so i was
able to go this is why i've written
700 episodes of radio and television
skit comedy
and finish one screenplay and i took all
the other screenplays and went
not gonna do those um what happened then
was i got such resistance from people
around me
what are you talking about you're
successful you're on national television
you have adhd
it's like richard branson owns an
airline he's got adhd
so i was so dismissed and kind of
humiliated and angry it stewed and
eventually with
a friend of mine patrick mckenna who
plays harold on the red green show
co-star he uh he decided i talked to him
very quickly because he's impulsive what
the heck
into doing a documentary about him
actually getting diagnosed his wife
who's not adhd was
alarmed and then went along with it and
it's been seen by another five or six
million people and
emails come in all the time so he just
saved my life my child is starting to
have a
dream they could have a life well let me
pick up on that because he was an adult
when he got diagnosed
as were you yeah i was 47. i thought
this was the kind of thing that you got
diagnosed when you were a kid
not in your case though no and in fact
for adults it's mine was the classic
your kid's diagnosed your kids suddenly
gifted
sprite suddenly struggling they do
analysis you know
testing they suggest adhd i'm a dad i'm
responsible let me see the list
what's wrong with this this is oh this
is this is and then everything makes
sense suddenly you realize why you're
really good at starting stuff not
finishing why you have so much on the go
why you tune out and you start to as i
start to learn especially about the
drd 4.7 the first gene that was
identified
thanks to some work done partly done
here at the university of toronto but
mostly
university of california irvine that was
the first gene that was identified
suspect gene
and then i went and i could look at my
dad i look at my grandfather who was on
the vaudeville stage
my dad stood wrestled his change and
keys as he watched tv
change channels go upstairs read a book
come back the light went on
yeah and he's in sales it was a perfect
job he's insurance talking to people
they want perfect job
and i'm in the perfect job so when you
find the right conditions you can soar
but if you don't know what's going on
and you're tuning out when your own
child is pouring their heart out from
you
you don't think i wonder if i'm low on
norepinephrine and dopamine you think
i'm a bad father i'm a really so the
relief
the anger the why didn't i know sooner
it's a
huge toxic mix we're dealing with on our
website on totally add people who've got
the diagnosis in their 70s they get the
diagnosis
they start treatment suddenly six months
later the house is clean
all the clutter's gone they're back
finishing courses the kids are coming
over because they can stand being around
they can listen they don't interrupt
and then they go oh my god life-changing
yeah but what if i'd known sooner
i wouldn't have gone through three
marriages and four bankruptcies and and
it's heartbreaking just for the record
you're not referring to yourself when
you say all this i've been through one
divorce and my finances are still a mess
i have a woman
a wife who does miracles for me and rule
number eight the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is channel your energy with ty
pennington
when i was in elementary school my
mother received countless phone calls
from my teachers
the principal's office and even my
guidance counselor because i was
constantly
in trouble for something whether it was
running around the classroom
jumping from the windowsill or just not
finishing my class work it seemed
as though i could never really
consistently work to my potential
my teachers pretty much insisted i was
bright but i just couldn't sit still
i couldn't control my impulsive
behaviors or concentrate long enough to
complete tasks
or even listen to simple instructions
now my mother a graduate student in
child psychology at the time
sensed that something wasn't right but
things really hit home when she was
asked
to analyze the most poorly behaved
student in my school and the principal
sent me well she made an appointment to
have me evaluated by a doctor who
confirmed that i had attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder otherwise known
adhd
however she did not inform me of the
doctor's diagnosis at the time
and as a child i didn't know that i had
adhd and was not treated for it
but i learned to cope with the symptoms
by channeling my energy into my passion
which is building things
the bigger the better now while these
creative outlets helped me control my
hyperactive and impulsive behaviors
i still had trouble focusing and
finishing things that i really wasn't
interested in
now getting through high school was a
struggle academically as well socially
uh it wasn't until i dropped out of my
first year college that i think my
mother realized
how much adhd was impacting me and how
it caused other people in my life to
have a negative opinion of me
so she sat me down and told me i had
adhd and suggested that i talked to my
doctor
well hearing that i had adhd really kind
of hit home everything started to make
sense to me my impulsive behaviors
my relationship or lack thereof and my
lack of focus and organization
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through but when you get
motivated inspired and you create a plan
of action
you have a over 90 chance of following
through and when you share with other
people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because
i want to celebrate you you've been part
of this campaign for a couple of years
now why is this so important to you
because it's important to talk for about
everything talking is the answer
it really is to every problem there is
you know if you have a problem you say
let's talk about it
and mental health is probably
the most pervasive
issue that anybody has and you don't
have to have ocd or adhd or
anxiety or depression like me and family
members have but
you just have to be human and the thing
is there's a stigma
about you know sharing your weakness or
your inability
to function and getting help about it i
believe that we should take care of our
mental health like we take care of our
dental health and i've listened to
people ad nauseam tell me about their
retainer and their root canal and how
they're taking care of their teeth but
what about how you're dealing
each and every day with whatever issue
you're dealing with well i'm very
comfortable with my discomfort
so i'm as uncomfortable talking about
that as i am
about my uh i don't have a retainer you
know
no i uh uh do you did you have one not
now
but mine's gold mine's built in i can't
get rid of it you have a built-in
retainer what do we do in canada now
are you serious i don't know i mean i
have one
[Music]
you say that now are you comfortable
talking about it well
i'm so used to it now but this help yes
and you went and got help right
and talking about it is the retainer for
our minds
growing up with him i got to see
everything that he's dealt with
and going through and as well as myself
um
i think that it does get passed down uh
and it's blaming me is what he's doing
yeah so it's his fault that i also have
add and anxiety and all that stuff but
it is something that affects me and i
think
that one thing that people don't talk
about is the effects of family as a
whole
even if only one member has that so i
think it's good that we
are doing this together because we've
had to deal with it together as a family
and we talk about it and we talk
[Music]
if you want to know why dyslexia can be
your advantage check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i never felt like a victim i think
in movies really helped me
kind of save me from shame take this
obstacle and make it the reason
to have a big life